it's the ultimate nightmare of any news
organization men armed with guns and a
frightening version of Islam showed up
and killed 12 people including several
of France's most popular political
cartoonists more were killed after a
massive manhunt and a hostage crisis
leaving French citizens traumatized
angry and confused Charlie Hebdo was a
leftist magazine that lampooned everyone
but some took offense and were prepared
to kill over it and unfortunately many
groups and individuals seized the
opportunity to gain from this so who
might benefit in the aftermath of this
attack racial anti-immigrant and
religious tensions have been brewing in
France and the whole of Europe for a
while in the past few months alone
mosques have been attacked in Sweden
synagogues have been targeted thousands
of Germans have marched against the
so-called Islamisation of the West and
the attack on Charlie Hebdo allows
parties like the from national to
capitalize on the sphere phobia Kremlin
met a lady Sylvia move more politic
cupid is a natural a senator am sure the
development immortalise Muslim Easter
don't copy many of these politicians
manipulate what it means to be liberal
and secular it's a war them barbarians
of the East versus us enlightened in the
West Muslims and other immigrants stand
to bear the brunt of the backlash and
there's more Isis and other violent
groups also have much to gain in moments
like this the shooters in Paris had
links to al-qaeda in Yemen as war rages
on in the Middle East these young
Europeans go in and out of war zones
often in the flesh sometimes only in
support online bringing the conflict
back home the sharply abdo attack allows
violent groups to gloat to celebrate and
promote their cause and if there's an
Islamophobic backlash against young
disenfranchised Muslims all the better
more potential recruits political
demagogues and clerics jump on the
bandwagon to remember the Danish
cartoons a decade ago a Danish newspaper
published satirical images of the
Prophet Muhammad millions were offended
yes but leaders religious and secular in
countries across the Muslim world
rallied their citizens sometimes
sanctioning violence and hundreds of
thousands of people took to the streets
embassies were attacked burnt to the
ground at least 250 people were killed
and hundreds more were injured
manipulating people to become so angry
about a picture and then kill over it is
a far more perverse art than any cartoon
equally skillful is to convince people
that the answer is less immigration
fewer Muslims and fewer rights for the
many as punishment for the actions of
the few less secular democracy because
of those who attacked secular democracy
so now what questions are asked inside
Islam about what it means to be Muslim
people within Europe question what it
means to be European what if you're both
and what do we do when satire crashes
into the sacred and leaves behind blood
for ink who do you think wins and losers
in this terrible tragedy the attack on
the offices of Charlie Hebdo was the
biggest affront to doodles since Anthony
weaner learn to use snapchat gunmen
stormed the office of satirical magazine
Charlie Hebdo reportedly opening fire on
an editorial meeting and saying the
Prophet Mohammed had been avenged